الان مع هذه الرساله الصوتيه التي وصلتنا
من الرائد محمود بصل الناطق باسم الدفاع
المدني في غزه
تابع يعني الواقع الان في قطاع غزه هو
واقع صعب جدا وواقع ماساوي ونحن
[موسيقى]
بنتحدى هذا اليوم الى عمليات قصف بشكل
كبير جدا هذه المنطقه التي تم قصف يعني
الكثير من الاهداف في هذه
المناطق يعني المكتظه بالسكان والتي تحتوي
على عدد كبير جدا من النازحين يعني منطقه
مستشفى ناصر المنطقه التي تعرضت الى
عمليات قصف بشكل كبير والاحتلال اسرائيلي
بشكل يعني لم يتوقف منذ صبيحه هذا اليوم
حتى هذه اللحظه في هذا المحيط مستشفى ناصر
ومحيط ايضا حي النمساوي حيث كانت القذائف
تسقط على رؤوس المواطنين بشكل كبير جدا
ويحضر الدخول والتحرك الى هذه المناطق
طبعا لتواجد الاليات الصهيونيه ولكثافة
كبيره وصلت الى مستشفى ناصر طبعا هؤلاء
الشهداء عدد منهم ايضا من الاطفال نتحدث
عن اكثر من 15 شهيد في هذه المنطقه وهناك
اعداد من هؤلاء الشهداء هم من الاطفال
وطواقم الدفاع المدني وطواقم ايضا وزاره
الصحه هناك صعوبه كبيره من الوصول الى هذه
المناطق من اجل انتشال الشهداء لكن
المواطنين وعبر يعني العربات يقومون بشكل
صعب جدا من عمليات انتشال هؤلاء او بعض
هؤلاء الشه شهداء وتحويلهم الى مستشفى
ناصر طبعا نتحدث ايضا عن استهداف لابراج
طيبه في منطقه خانيونس والمعسكر الغربي
ايضا على يعني شقق سكنيه في هذه في هذه
الابراج تم استهدافها من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهناك ايضا قذائف
بشكل كبير تسقط على هذه المنطقه ايضا
منطقه جامعه الاقصى التي الان يعني تستهدف
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عبر
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تطلق قذائفها
على هذه المنطقه وايضا تطلق يعني الرشاشات
على منطقه جامعه الاقصى والتي تحتوي على
عدد كبير والاف النازحين المتواجدين فيها
منذ بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع
وحتى يعني هذه اللحظه ايضا تم انتشال
شهيده طفله صغيره تبلغ من العمر 12 عام من
مدرسه خلديه غرب مدينه خانيونس والتي يعني
تم استشهادها نتيجه اطلاق القذائف
الصاروخيه على هذه المدرسه و تم يعني
تحويلها الى مستشفى ناصر طبعا نتحدث عن
واقع صعب جدا في منطقه خانيونس ايضا يعني
في منطقه مدينه غزه الان والتي تتعرض منذ
فجر هذا اليوم الى عمليات قصف مدفعي بشكل
هستيري من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
طبعا شارع ثمانيا منطقه تل الهواء شارع
الرشيد كل هذه المناطق التي تم استهدافها
بال بال الصواريخ الحربيه وتم استهدافها
ايضا بالمدفع حتى هذه اللحظه هذا هو
الواقع حتى هذه اللحظه وطواقم الدفاع
المدني يعني تحاول قدر المستطاع من التحرك
والوصول الى هذه المناطق التي يعني
استهدفت والتي لا شك انه يوجد بداخلها او
في هذه في اماكن الاستهداف اعداد من
الشهداء والجرحى لكن صعوبه الوصول الى هذه
المناطق هو الذي يحول من يعني تحرك
الطواقم والوصول الى هذه المناطق ننتظر
حقيقه ان يعني تهدا الامور نوعا ما من اجل
يعني انتشال ما يمكن انتشاله من الشهداء
والجرحى الم واجدين في هذه
المناطق